hey what is up guys mkbhd here my go-to
wireless earbuds for the past couple
years have been jaybird bluebuds these
are jaybird freedom they were unveiled
at ces earlier this year and they're
supposed to be their most advanced
bluetooth earbuds yet and for 200 bucks
they probably should be so it's a new
design new tech essentially trying to
make them the new best wireless earbuds
you can buy so design is already pretty
similar to the jaybird x2s but as you
can see the earbud itself is now much
smaller so think like the klipsch x10
sort of design so it's essentially a
hybrid between these two products it's
taking the best of both worlds the best
of the clip x10 design is the size the
design is so small even compared to
other earbuds these are super light the
whole thing is just 13 grams and when
you're wearing them it almost feels like
there's nothing in your ear which makes
them of course super comfortable and
they use a micro tapered earbud design
which makes a nice seal like a normal
earbud but then it just goes like
straight 90 degrees and comes down out
the bottom of your ear so you can go
over ear or under ear wing tips or no
wing tips a foam tip or rubber tip
whatever you want there's plenty of ways
for them to be comfortable
and then again the designs biggest
advantage is the size so even the
smallest of other earbuds do usually
stick out the sides of your ears a
little bit
this design doesn't so that's what makes
them helmet friendly or hat friendly etc
basically you can wear whatever headwear
you want over your ears and it doesn't
push up against the earbuds so that's
unique to these now the best of the
jaybird bluebuds series is the tech for
sure these are super high-tech earbuds
first of all wireless bluetooth 4.1 so
you can have them paired to two devices
at once which is pretty dope so you
don't have to pair and unpair them over
and over to switch devices and you get
inline controls a microphone a charging
indicator light and overall a high-end
package as far as earbuds go it's just
what you're used to from previous
jaybird stuff now jaybird claims eight
hours of battery life from this much
smaller design which would be amazing
except it isn't eight hours so the
battery has moved from the earbud to the
controller since obviously there's no
more space in the earbuds for batteries
and it's actually a four hour battery
life with the smaller battery here plus
an additional four hours with the
charging cradle that has a small battery
built into it so this charging cradle
that comes with the earbuds just kind of
snaps into place and charges via those
pins at a pretty decent rate and it can
add an hour of playback time in 20
minutes of wireless charging so that's
nice but also definitely make sure you
don't lose it because it's required to
charge the earbuds at all since that's
where the only micro usb port lives so
basically i don't really think it's fair
to call this an eight hour battery life
i mean i get it you can total eight
hours but that's like claiming a
smartphone has a three-day battery life
because you can attach this external
battery you can use it while it's
attached but most people probably won't
actually do that so yeah i call it a
four hour battery life but that's
actually still pretty good considering
they charge fast and you actually have a
pretty good idea of how much battery you
have left most of the time because it
tells you every time you turn it on and
it monitors the exact percentage in the
jaybird app so now a low battery isn't a
surprise anymore like it used to be and
that
is the killer feature the cherry on top
is the jaybird my sound app basically
you grab this app once on your iphone or
android phone or whatever you have and
you pair the earbuds this way instead of
the normal bluetooth menu and once it's
paired the app knows everything about
your headphones so what kind they are
how much battery you have left and what
sound signature you're using and you can
actually change that sound signature of
the earbuds on the fly there's a bunch
of built-in presets to choose from you
can find more presets to pick or you can
customize and build your own and there's
a built-in tool to get really granular
and specific about how you want yours to
sound so they already sound really good
for any earbuds they're crisp and clean
way better than you'd probably expect
out of six millimeter drivers but if you
decide you want say a little more bass
or a little more mids or less treble or
whatever you want you can adjust and
color the sound with this app and it
actually adjusts the firmware of the
earbuds so any device or any app you
listen to after adjusting it in the my
sound app will still use this sound so
that's key so let's say you add a ton of
bass you love bass you had a ton of bass
on day one with the my sound app then
you could pair it a week later to your
ipad and fire up i don't know apple
music and it'll still have all that bass
or connect it to a new smartphone a
month later you get a new phone and you
fire up spotify or soundcloud it will
still have all that added bass that you
like so that's really cool you get the
fine-tuned control of how the earbuds
sound and even if like you uninstall the
my sound app the next day the adjusted
sound follows your earbuds around until
you change it again yourself and pro tip
you actually get a live preview of the
sound the second you change it so you
can have some music playing in another
app in the background and mess around
with the sound signatures live until you
find one you like
so that's what you're looking at a
pretty great hybrid package in the
jaybird freedom
overall do you have to get these
no of course not in fact unlike
smartphones or laptops something like
headphones doesn't turn over and become
obsolete or dead year after year so if
you have a good wireless pair of earbuds
now that sounds great then that works
for you but if you're in the market for
a new pair for working out or running or
just walking to work like you just don't
have one yet then yeah this would be
just about the top notch pair you can
get super small and light 30 foot
wireless range sweat proof super durable
and customizable sound like what more
could you want so there you have it the
jaybird freedom is definitely the
complete package as far as high-tech
wireless earbuds go thanks for watching
this video and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one peace